Find the volume of a cube with
a side length of 8xy squared.
So we have a cube right here.
And they're saying that each of
the sides, for a cube all
the sides have the same length,
each of them have
length 8xy squared.
So the length of this side,
maybe we call this the width,
is 8xy squared.
The length of this side, maybe
we can call that the depth, or
the length, depending
on how you want to
label it, is 8xy squared.
The height of this cube is also
going to be 8xy squared.
A cube, all of the dimensions
are the same.
Now, if you want to take the
volume of any a rectangular
prism, you'll multiplied
these three dimensions.
You"ll multiply the
width times the
depth times the height.
Now, in a cube, these are
all the same dimensions.
So you can just take this
dimension and multiply it by
itself three times.
Or you could take it
to the third power.
So the volume of this cube is
8xy squared, I could just
multiply it by itself three
times, or I could say to the
third power.
That's why raising something
to the third power is
called cubing it.
Because you're essentially
finding the volume of a cube,
where the thing that you're
cubing is the dimension of
each of the sides.
Now, what's this going to be?
Well, when you take a product
and you raise it to some
power, that's the same thing as
taking each of the terms to
that power.
So this is the same thing as 8
to the third power times x to
the third power times y squared
to the third power.
And what's 8 to the
third power?
8 squared is 64, so we'll
multiply 64 times 8.
4 times 8 is 32.
6 times 8 is 48 plus 3 is 51.
So it's 512.
So this is equal to 512 times
x to the third and y squared
to the third power, that's the
same thing is y to the 2 times
3 power, or y to the
sixth power.
And we're done.
We found the volume
of the cube.
It's 512 x to the third
y to the sixth.